hé hé
c'est la fin de la formation de ses 23
élèves gardent ils vont officiellement
devenir cavaliers de la garde
républicaine durant cette cérémonie
présidée par le colonel gabriel cortès
commandant du régiment de cavalerie des
élèves sont présentés à l'étendard le
drapeau tricolore avec la devise honneur
et patrie
ils représentent tous ceux qui nous ont
précédés en particulier ceux qui sont
morts au combat et c'est pourquoi dans
ses plis sont inscrits cinq batailles
aux victoires de lempire jusqu'à
d'indochine jusqu'à la guerre
d'indochine pour devenir cavalier une
formation au centre d'instruction de la
garde républicaine à saint germain en
laye est nécessaire rattaché à la
gendarmerie nationale les cavaliers
assure le protocole notamment lors de
défilés militaires ou de cérémonie ils
ont aussi des missions de sécurité
publique à cheval ça peut être des
gendarmes adjoints volontaires avec des
contrats courts de six mois ça peut être
des gendarmes de carrière ou qui vont
devenir de carrière les instructeur
d'équitation au centre d'instruction de
la cavalerie de la garde républicaine
près de 200 stagiaires sont accueillis
chaque année ils sont formés par une
dizaine d'instructeurs pendant 15
semaines à travers plusieurs
enseignements
la formation théorique c'est l'école du
cavalier l'hippologie tout le savoir que
chaque homme de cheval doit doit
acquérir pour être opérationnel la
formation technique
donc là on aborde toutes les matières
académiques les disciplines académiques
que sont le cso dressage par exemple et
la formation spécifique qui est propre
au régiment de cavalerie l'intervention
professionnelle lippé et l'ordre serré
loes concernant les recrutements pour
intégrer ce centre les élèves gardent
viennent le plus souvent de l'école de
gendarmerie
alors là je suis musicien de formation
je suis tromboniste je ne voulais pas
forcément continuer la musique en dans
les salles à l'intérieur jouer un métier
à l'extérieur mêlant l'environnement
militaire et la musique ou
l'environnement militaire et
l'excitation que j'avais commencé un
petit peu dans le civil la gendarmerie
ça m'a permis de pouvoir m'épanouir plus
professionnellement et pouvoir le
combiné à ma passion en intégrant le
régiment de cavalerie a été une chance
pour moi
donc effectivement j'ai commencé avec
une école de gendarmerie et après j'ai
pu choisir la garde républicaine
grâce aux compétences que j'ai eues en
passant des tests lagarde bérénice va
rejoindre le quartier carnot à vincennes
de son côté le gars de romain va
rejoindre la fanfare de la cavalerie la
garde républicaine compte près de 3000
militaires dans ses rangs